joining us now the author of the
brand-new book let's move on beyond fear
and false prophets former Mexican
President Vicente Fox is with a sir good
to see you how are you Sean a pleasure
to have you
well we've got some fights before oh
we're done when you were president in
the year 2002 you deported you kicked
out of your country a hundred and forty
thousand people that entered Mexico in
America Nicaragua Guatemala El Salvador
you threw them out and you say if we do
that we're racist and this is unfair and
unkind and unjust you did the very thing
you don't want us to do
no this is an issue that I agree with
you 100% so we should check out illegals
wait a minute
borders must be secure and borders must
be safe and we must keep orbiter like we
tried to do with President Bush with
Senator McCain with senator Kennedy we
put it together a bill that is presented
in Congress in the US with all of this
issue why did you call the walls stupid
why did you you know give the middle
finger tell Trump to go to hell F Trump
you've said all these things why if the
wall is good why don't you say build the
wall like Trump said with a door and we
can let our friends in but not the drug
dealers they're not against the wall
it's good if you want to build the wall
what we're against is Mexico paying for
that stupid idea
making Mexico pay for the wall
I know very ways of negotiating it's a
win-win situation where we both can win
but anyway all of that is dealt in the
book on let's move ahead it's and it's
not on this candle book it's not a book
to confront its reasoning ideas is
bringing proposals that's what you're
gonna read it so
who pays for images oh wow that America
builds on the southern border you can
forget about the payment if we build the
wall but I think Mexico and I think we
should be best friends I think America
and Canada should be best friends Mexico
Canada and the United States should all
be best friends but we need to protect
our homeland and I think you disrespect
them and security in the border and I
work six years with President Bush for
that purpose we came in with this
partnership for prosperity and security
we came out with a NAFTA blues that
included security so no no no problem
with that I'm with that they wait to do
it offending calling Mexicans criminals
I mean he said some be fair Mexico
sending the worst and 35 million
Hispanics work here and make this
country competitive to become citizens
and here's the thing you you agree in
the rule of law right you're okay so if
you don't respect American law and you
come here illegally then you didn't
respect our laws and sup women all these
people want to come in why don't we give
it to the people that do it the right
way respect our laws this is not the
United States I know this is not the
United the shortest founding fathers
absolutely is knows my grandpa women all
four of my grandparents came from
Ireland yes and they came through Ellis
Island yeah they didn't have any money
they were broke and they came here
legally what we're saying is we're gonna
be good neighbors you have to respect
our border respect yes never spectra
work and that and that's what we did
with President Bush to come up with wise
bright idea is not this thick anymore
that doesn't help image of United why do
you call the president stupid he can go
to hell
you put your middle finger up you say
you know he's an idiot the effing wall
why do you say all of that because
that's what we're gonna get
saying that's what I perceived from him
I invited him to come he went to Mexico
he met with your president I'm the
president historical mistake because
that's why today I was a mistake you
want to talk we want a solution Trump is
president he shouldn't have been but
anyway that's a no no no no he should
have been because the American people
decided 30% under people no excuse me
47% how many people vote what percent
voted for you percent support for me 36%
okay so everything you didn't have a
majority didn't go against opposition I
tried to unite Bernie Sanders on igano
get bipartisan agreements you are a lot
calmer this time than the last time we
had a big fight I would say we need
borders to protect our country agree
with okay and I would say the
president's right I don't need walls you
need borders walls you built for there's
a race to keep me
oh let us decide what we're gonna do
with a big door and we can all be
friends but America has the right not to
let people okay so the walls built with
a big door you'd be happy with the wall
with a big door that you don't have a
window with a door that people come
legally I don't mind being built here I
just try to advise American citizens my
loved country United States don't waste
your money which is all be friends
that's what we're working for nice to
see you
god bless you cluster bar as you make